I do admire very different for me but I
admire Mr Beast who unapologetically
says like the number is all that matters
like basically the number
shows like the number of views you get
shows like how much
uh I don't know Joy you brought to
people's lives because if they watch the
thing they kept watching the thing they
didn't turn to now that means they loved
it you brought value to their life you
brought enjoyment and I'm going to bring
the the maximum amount of enjoyment to
the maximum number of people and I'm
gonna do the most epic videos and all
that kind of stuff so I admire that when
you're so unapologetically into the
numbers yeah he's sort of it's
interesting he's like
gosh we're getting way too in the
weights am I is this a I don't know I'm
like constantly self-monitoring about
like what topics put on but if we can Mr
Beast is so interesting because he's
almost done what have you ever seen
Moneyball
uh yes it's the story of how someone
brought statistics to baseball and it
revolutionized everything he's
moneyballed YouTube yeah he took
statistics to YouTube and it changed
everything and everybody now
so many people are playing catch-up I
think it would be interesting
in a few years to see how he develops
and now that he's like kind of
revolutionized like the data side of
things
how he then approaches future videos
because there's a point at which
you've optimized you've optimized you've
optimized but optimizing for short-term
video performance is not the same as
optimizing for long-term viewer
happiness yeah and how do you do that
assuming the YouTube algorithm does not
perfectly already do it for you which it
doesn't but they're trying to obviously
do that optimize for long-term happiness
but and also growing Optimizer for
long-term creative growth sure I think
the thing that people don't I mean maybe
I don't know I don't actually don't know
enough about Jimmy but like to me the
thing that seems to be special about him
isn't the Money Ball aspect that that's
really important it's like taking the
data seriously but to me is that the
part of the idea generation
the constant brainstorming coming up
with videos so it's nice to connect the
idea generation with the with the data
but like how many people when they
create on YouTube and other platforms
really generate a huge amount of ideas
like constantly brainstorm constant
constantly brainstorm at least for me I
don't
I don't like I don't think I go uh so
many steps ahead in my thinking I don't
like try to come up with all possible
conversations that don't come up with
all possible videos I can make but but
you can't so the one mistake to make is
to and map Jimmy's philosophy onto every
genre because not every genre fits that
model your model is not an idea Centric
model it's a people-centric model and so
you like
if you were in the business of creating
just Mass entertainment for the sake of
mass entertainment you might focus on
Okay the reason going idea focused
instead of person focused is so such a
revolutionary idea in some senses is
because ideas can be broader more
broadly appealing than any single human
can be
but you're not going for that you're
going for a podcast interview and I
think for you
the goal should always be how deep can
you get with interesting guests and like
finding the most interesting guest which
is a different probably set of skills
than well really well put but I think
the the right mapping there is finding
the most interesting guests yeah and I I
think uh I don't do enough work on that
so for example I I I I try to be
something I do prioritize is is talking
to people that nobody's talked to before
so
because it's like I kind of my see
myself as not a good like I know a lot
of people are much better than me I
really admire I think uh uh Joe Rogan is
still the goat he's just an incredible
conversationalist so it's like all right
who is somebody Joe's not gonna talk to
uh
not either he's not interested it's not
it's not gonna happen like I want to
talk to that person I want to I want to
reveal the interesting aspect of that
person and I think
I should do a Mr B style rigger
in searching for interesting people and
you should probably find people to help
you search sure so he does that but if
you're being honest he does that of
course with other other folks but he's
the main engine yeah you need like sort
of like a a pre-filter you're the final
filter because your problem is
your only able to think of humans that
you've thought of before or been exposed
to and most of the world you've never
been exposed to so you need people to
like pre-filter and go okay these guys
are just interesting humans Lexus never
heard of them and then you sort of take
a batch of like a hundred people and you
go who seems the most interesting for me
yeah but by the way on that topic we're
always into weeds I have uh almost done
on building up uh I I programmed uh this
guest recommendation thing where I want
to get suggestions from other people
because I really want to find people
that nobody knows this is the tricky
thing like not you're not famous but I I
the the idea is there's probably
fascinating humans out there that nobody
knows correct that I want to find those
and I believe in the crowdsourcing
aspect we'll raise them and now of
course the top hundred will be crypto
scams no but yes so like I have to make
sure that these kinds of swarms of human
humans that recommend I can filter
through and there's this whole kinds of
systems for that but I want to find the
the fascinating people out there that
nobody's ever heard from and um
from a programmer perspective I thought
surely I could do that by just building
the system yeah that's how programmers
always think they'll just automate a
system to do it well that's the Jimmy
Moneyball right like looking at the data